Welcome to Elimination Creek Country Club.
I believe you know your way around, Dak.
Just give me a drink.
This sucks.
We are very depressed.
The club is nice.
I’m getting almost as much rest
as I did in the Wild Card Game.
Yeah.
Now all the charities
know I have free time....
FUDGE THE OFFSEASON!
I WANT FRICKIN' FOOTBALL!
Phil, Phil, PHIL, PHIL!
Can I just run it?
Hey, maybe I—
Sorry, sir.
Starters only at the club.
I’M ELITE.
I’ll be one of Washington’s
five starting quarterbacks next year.
Not again.
YOU GOT THIS.
NEVER CHOKE.
BELIEVE IN YOURSELF.
All right
well great season everyone.
See you next year! Much love.
By the way, man
I’m totally cool with outbursts.
So now that my fourth OC has left
I have to wonder
am I the problem?
CANNONBALL, hahaha!
Tough elimination, man.
That’s OK!
This time last year
I was legally dead lol.
BRING IT ON!
OH NO. MY POWER ZONE!
I’M TRANSFORMING BACK
TO REGULAR-SEASON NICK.
So the trick is to just have
your family yell at the owners—
OW, DADDY!
Must be the players on the
playoff course across the street.
Can you throw it back?
It’s only like 400 yards.
Why are you having fun?
This is a game.